[Music]
Melinda is in Syracuse New York I'm
Melinda how are you hi Dave I am good I
just had a quick question I found out
that I am a document hoarder and I'm
trying to clear my what I keep I did
find the paperwork online that you had
on your website but some of them I was
confused about I didn't know what to do
with documents for student loans for a
past rental contract or an old mortgage
because I sold I sold a place that I had
how long ago was the mortgage three
years ago okay I mean I keep stuff
that's big items like that about five
years I would want to keep it at least
that long something that's a big deal
anything that was ever a settled debt or
a disputed debt I keep that one forever
because that can come back to haunt you
later and you're gonna have to have the
written proof so I keep the hard paper
on all that stuff anything like that and
so but you know a lot of people back in
the day we used to get in the mailbox we
would get all our checks and a checking
account statement before everything was
done online and I've met people that
have there every one of their checking
account statements and all their
canceled checks for for twenty years in
their attic and you know that starts to
get up you know starts to get to be a
problem yeah so then you know you just
clean all that out but anything that
feels like it's big I mean keeping a
copy of your old paid off mortgage from
three years ago is not a big item it's
you know should be a two page piece of
paper well I used to keep all my utility
bills for like the last ten years
yeah there's useless yep I found that
out from your page yeah yeah so you know
you're right you know you just got a
transfer form to a paper a paperless or
close to paperless existence is a good
idea just in terms of you've got more
access to it than rummaging through the
attic trying to find it but you can go
back on utility bills again online
in almost every municipality now and and
the only reason you do not need to know
your old utility bills somebody buying
your house you can prove to them what
the electric bills been or what the
water bills been in this area and you
can we used to print them off and lay
them out on the counter when we were
when I was a realtor 100 years ago and
just so you could look okay here's the
last 12 gas bills electric bills and
water bills and they're laying there so
they know what they're going to be and
but you can just print that off as a
printout now from online if you wanted
to and again you don't have to keep that
kind of stuff so hey good question
interesting discussion